People even now,
because it's the 100th anniversary of
the Russian revolution,
are celebrating Lennon.
It's like,
that's not good.
That's like celebrating Hitler.
Okay,
I'm dead serious about that.
It's not good,
and the fact that people can dare to
think that that's okay means that
there's something wrong with the way
that we look at history.
Lennon was a monster and if you want to
know about that,
you can read Solzhenitsyn's writings
about lending because they communist
apologists say,
well,
it wasn't landing.
Len was a good guy.
He was all motivated by love of the
working class.
It's like,
well,
his henchmen was stolen and if you're
Hansman is Stellan,
you're not a good guy and lender who was
around during the early collectivization
and if you read what he wrote,
you'll find out that he is perfectly
willing to have any number of people die
as long as his ideological system could
be brought into big.
So there's no celebrating Lennon.
There's no work,
cool young Marxist hip revolutionaries
and he's our idol.
It's like there's none of that.
Not if you know anything,
not if you're decent,
whether it's death of the Kulaks I told
you about that there was the Ukrainian
famine.
That's 6 million gone there.
There was the rise of the Gulag state
because it turned out that Russia,
the Soviet Union couldn't run on the
principles that it had that had,
had a laid down as sacrosanct that just
didn't work.
So he had to enslave everybody and run
your economy
as a slave state essentially.
And try not to kill the people in the
gulags so fast that you can't suck some
productive labor out of them is the
death of tens of millions of people.
We don't even know the estimates range
from 15 to $60 million and like we won't
get it to Picayune about the numbers
because after the first 10 million you
kinda made your point and the fact that
we don't know between 15 and 60 is
actually an indication.
Yeah,
of the horror of it because our count is
off by tens of millions and that's only
within the last century.
And then there was the 1956 crackdown on
Hungary and the 1968 invasion of
Czechoslovakia.
Then there was the whole like thermo
nuclear Holocaust thing that was going
on at the same time,
and the fact that in 1962 and in 1984,
we were seconds away from complete
annihilation,
right during the Cuban missile crisis,
the keys were in the intercontinental
ballistic missile release systems.
And Castro,
as he admitted to Jimmy Carter in case
any of you are Castro fans,
which you shouldn't be,
that he was perfectly willing to have
Cuba annihilated if it would've meant
the defeat of the United States.
And then in 1984 approximately,
I may have the date exactly wrong,
the Russians received an indication from
their early warning systems that the
Americans had launched five Thurman
Nuclear Missiles and one Russian decided
that it was a mistake and refused to
launch the retaliation.
And he just died about two weeks ago.
So,
you know,
that was pretty close.
And uh,
so that was experiment number one.
Let's say that that wasn't good,
that experiment,
let's put it that way.
It wasn't good.
It was exactly the antithesis of good.
It was precisely the antithesis of good,
but that wasn't all.
I mean,
there's the People's Republic of China.
That's a different country,
like seriously,
a different country,
right?
Different tradition,
different language.
How many people died in China under Mao?
No one knows.
Same issue with the Soviet Union.
Although mile was a bigger monster than
Stalin and that's.
That's impressive.
You know,
because there's Hitler,
there's Stalin and Mao and of the three
mile was probably the worst.
He's still revered in China.
Maybe that accounts for their affinity
for North Korea,
which could still destroy us.
All the remnants of that horrible state.
Maybe a 100 million people died in China
during the great leap forward.
That's a hell of a leap forward.
Well,
maybe it wasn't a 100 million,
you know,
maybe it was only $40 million,
but as I said before,
when you're counting in the tens of
millions of your points already made,
and then there was Cambodia and the
killing fields and Bulgaria and east
Germany and Romania and the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea.
That's North Korea and Vietnam and
Ethiopia.
Hungary,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
There was never a successful communist
state.
Cuba,
I suppose,
came closest,
but it was radically,
um,
the Soviets poured money into Cuba.
So that doesn't really count.
So then the first question was,
well,
are these Marxists motivated by love or
hatred?
Well,
is it love or hatred that produces $100,
million dead people?
Is that enough evidence or not?
And if it's not enough evidence,
if you think to yourself,
well,
that's not enough evidence,
it was never really given its proper,
a proper try.
It's like,
well,
why would have been a proper try to.
I always think when I hear someone say
that I know what you think,
you think in your delusional arrogance,
that you understand the Marxist
doctrines better than anyone else ever
has,
and that if you were one implementing
those doctrines,
you would have ushered in the utopia.
That's what you mean when you say that
and no,
they're there.
They saying there's an idea in the new
testament that there is a sin.
It's a sin against the holy ghost.
If you commit that sand,
no one really knows what it is that you
can't be forgiven,
and I would say,
well,
if you want a candidate for the sin
against the Holy Ghost and the 21st
century,
the statement communism,
real communism was never tried with the
underlying idea that if you had been the
person implementing it would have
worked.
I think that's pretty good contender for
something for which you should never be
forgiven.